[Music]
to different people all right in sexual
hearing news oh I want some always
actual good sore you just said sexual
healing with the fake Japanese actual
hearing to sexual hearing submitted by
beats by Bart a in that year yeah he's
sorry he apparently people are now
having sex while wearing air pods whoa I
like I took a big turn Airport there
already a big turn-off
what if the the guy it doesn't know how
to dirty talk very well and so she puts
on a tape book oh yeah girls dick [ __ ]
me - I need the motivation oh my god I'm
not like a cheerleader yeah I need some
instruction oh it's always like first
insert is it because they're so
expensive and Mooji
yeah oh that is the next level douche
bag right is it yes there is a study
conducted by tick pick which is an
online ticketing marketplace they found
that one in five air pod owners claimed
to have had sex while wearing them why
so they're saying that you know they
like to listen to the music in their ear
and it may be different me dude I
fifteen they're like friends do anything
without my air patru girl if you have
sex with a guy with sunglasses on and
you're like what have you ever have it
no but I've seen it like I said wait no
no no no no over there let me just start
again so no your sex life oh no it
wasn't mine but I have seen it where
like it's been like pictures like on
Twitter or like you've seen like I know
it's happened is that buck was there
chains on yeah well not even there
chains were like sunglasses I remember
seeing him being like oh my [ __ ] god
I would never because that just is so
dehumanizing it makes them feel cool
right but who the [ __ ] do you think
you're watching live or something and
you're just seeing pictures of blind
like dese's triggered and offended yeah
she dates a blind Japanese like those
blind people one yeah can you imagine if
we had sex with those feel like stopping
about my boyfriend yeah he took him home
that's why he's planning he's wearing
them right now at karate camp there's no
chance that they just had like forgot to
take them off like they're claiming they
like to listen to Mike that's our theme
I gotta listen to my Jam's but you can't
listen to my channel you got like music
on while you're having sex
I like okay just for me give me your
thing Oh what if they don't like the
same music cuz I feel like I don't want
to hear what Joe probably wants to
[ __ ] play Michael Jackson lower head
oh my god that does sound like Joe
teller beat it or something I'm like
these are sexy stop beating or did you
[ __ ] to a temple I mean I'm just saying
if you have it's like but what it's like
the guys listening to heavy metal and
then the girls listening to like kpop or
something and he's just like [ __ ] and
then she's like I feel like I'll be kind
of cool for an experience where you're
like alright let's try this but if
that's like a challenge
wait what is this them from those
parties where you go and everybody has
their own thing the silent party they
all have the same music though in the
headphones they're all listening to the
same song so what is this article about
it's just that there's do it now people
are [ __ ] with era but both people
have them are just one person so they're
saying that it seems like it's just that
one person that's like enjoying your
music or like so they could share if
it's like body G oh maybe if you're at
the park and you're like ooh looks like
have super stags yeah like let's have
secret sex I'm like you know you put
music and like you're sharing you know
but if only one person like that's kind
of like the sensitize so you know what I
mean like you're over there and I'm over
here and like you're just okay would you
rather have sex with someone wearing air
paws or have sex with someone wearing
socks that they've been walking in all
day oh I don't give a [ __ ] about sock
air but people have a problem with that
I've heard that yeah I don't come
talking about so I see you getting dick
I don't care if you're wearing socks or
not what about airpot jeez can you do
thing that I hear is like person doesn't
like wearing socks themselves oh no I've
heard that day it was people mall [ __ ] a
guy that's wearing socks I can't hello
it will have sex with someone why is
that such a big deal I feel
like I would just be like I mean yeah
you could take em on you taking off any
better
yeah you're not taking them off and it
has to stay on and they're that nasty
[ __ ] stinky ass socks I could smell
his feet in the [ __ ] you know the
blankets are going up and down and it's
lazy well you guys might know something
funny when I was younger like in the
costs more like 17 Maggie's no it wasn't
17 it was probably cost more something
like that
it said like when you're getting like
you know sexual yeah spicy because they
didn't say sexual spicy what the guy and
like you're undressing him start with
his socks because then it's awkward to
take everything off and then decide the
socks and that you work your way I've
never liked like getting a guy to like
give you it's good you're like give me
your son I'll see you do it I don't know
why do you have to take it yeah it's
awesome I mean in mind I keep like all
right we're gonna have to what do you
guys like getting undressed or would you
rather just undress yourself I mean it's
just gonna happen yeah and like me to I
kind of defense with generally though
most of the time we end up just and
dressing like I kind of start I'm like
okay here and it doesn't rush for him
but like for me he likes me to start
clothed and he likes to undress oh
that's dope yeah cuz we have for us it's
like we're kind of just exchange oh and
it's like okay I'll just do the rest let
me just grab her iam just get the
[ __ ] logo but yeah I mean I don't
know this is I I kind of want to try to
sex sex challenge airport fiction
wholly-owned air pods but I just had fun
because you're out of a job okay I got
it's all baby shark
baby shot meme that was sensing our girl
chat what was it like it says like call
me daddy
cute he's like him like call me daddy
and then she starts singing that yeah
that's enough sex while listening to
baby shark yeah I could do it yeah good
you already listed you that it's already
playing in the other room I could just
see you like building a temple you're
like I feel like well you have kids it's
like YouTube's playing like Coco mellon
and you're just like [ __ ] out let's get
it on I can't have sex I can't have sex
if he's awake
that's the enemy's in the other room if
I hear him it's all your talk about
barred at first you have to be dead
asleep and dry [ __ ] ever oh my god no
it's like can you guys buck to like a TV
show or a movie plenty thing I could
[ __ ] to anything cuz I used to be able
to but then now I get too distracted
like actually paying attention to my
[ __ ] you gotta be here yeah right yeah I
used to always know what happened with
him too because what he's not connected
we both we're both like really creeped
into it you're putting on a show that
you actually want to watch so you're
like I'll [ __ ] we're missing like
episode two
that's happened - no because then I
start paying attention to what they're
saying it could be like the shittiest
thing ever that I don't care about but
like I'm still paying attention to that
and it's dry it's taking me away from
being in the moment you got your hair
your hair pulled or something you know
[ __ ] slap you a little bit got like a
little slap we're [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
no hair-pulling or joking I don't like
that if you do one of those oh it's like
I try not to watch not to watch it so
you have your favorite show playing but
like he's like no you're watching that's
the second challenge read a lot John
does very much for everyone well as a
mother you have a boyfriend that lives
far away like how do you guys deal with
that yeah how do you guys have sex you
have phone sex face I was about to but
nothing your buddy did girl oh no no no
I mean yeah I guess face you get it on
on FaceTime a little bit but I mean you
get it on in person more like the whole
time and it's funny cuz people make fun
of us and they're like we already know
what's going on like as soon as Tony
touches down they're like we're not
texting or messaging her about like
anything you guys like binge sex yeah
it's like binge sexing
it's fun it's cool I mean it keeps it
like a lot more fresh than like if you
always see your partner and they're just
like always here
it's a we know yeah yeah yeah rub it in
our [ __ ] face enjoy while he's gone
as long as you can't keep him far away
Wow
yeah that's where in the beginning yeah
we were for a year and then it was like
like great yeah it was great the sex was
great and then we moved in and like
probably like especially like two years
after we moved in together so like third
year of having sex it was like a camp
board I both of us you know not just one
of you guys been together um two years
possibly two years long-distance yeah
yeah so it's keeping it fresh rush it
you guys were away it probably felt
super hard right yeah it was emotionally
hard yeah sex is still good yeah it's
kind of like being celibate and then not
being celibate and then being celibate
it's like fasting Berbers yeah yeah it's
like not eating at all and eating a
whole lot of donuts yeah top hubsan to
us each other every three months oh
that's so mom how often would do a seat
Oh like every three weeks wait how far
were ya Texas Texas oh you're across the
country right yeah and he's in school so
that's what kind of makes good like
three months that's crazy
I couldn't deal I think we we moved in
together after two months Oh law was a
heart but like no because I had already
known him for four years and so then we
started dating and it was just like wow
you had already known yet oh yeah you've
been friends with him for four years and
like we saw how each other were in
relationships and like we're both like
really loyal people and like he was
exactly how I am in a relationship and
our partners were opposites of us Oh God
so we both got dumps around the same
time and then we we went on a date and
it was just like boom magic and then I
was like in two months it was like let's
move in and then it's been great when
you broke up with your other dude do you
feel like super heartbroken when he
dumped me yeah well he cheated on me and
then yeah and I found out and then I
mean I guess I would I didn't get dumped
I chose to Liana to return to that
situation but yeah it was that was
really hard because that was like like
in the past I was the one breaking up
like I was the one that was kind of done
you know and like that was one that was
like I wasn't done
yeah but then he came in and I was like
oh my god I can't believe I was sweating
that guy yeah for because he's like way
better yeah yeah
[Music]